Je suis reconnaissant pour ma femme Deborah J'espère
qu'un jour notre famille sera aussi gentille que la tienne
tu penses que je suis un enfant gâté tu aimes
être mince les filles pas de moteur j'aime la façon dont
tu prends soin
quelqu'un veut que quelqu'un meure une question
bon suivi  les ordres
vous avez tout le jeu
je suis bon dans ce que je fais qu'en est-il de laisser des
témoins sur une scène de meurtre je ne tue pas de
femmes ou d'enfants vous savez si c'était
vrai alors je n'aurais rien à perdre d'
accord les enfants c'est tout
continuez donc est-ce mon jour de chance dans mon dernier a
eu une seconde essayant d'être mon partenaire tu
t'occupes des détails
pendant que
j'apprends plus de coquilles tu fais des coups
derrière mon dos pauvres fils de [ __ ]
pensant que leur père est un gars décent nous
se croisent à nouveau et Ameri toute ta
famille
dan viens pas maintenant devrait avoir peur hein
je ne savais pas que je suis censé avoir peur en
cherchant la glace maintenant la charge des
redevances pour les gros titres là-bas
que priez-
vous descendez et économisez  ça vient,
arrête-moi, je pense que Dieu est occupé
yo  tu